[Music]
[Applause]
all right fan corrections this is a
segment where viewers try to find
mistakes on our show
impossible
so far hundreds and hundreds of
challengers not one winner we've never
made a mistake never ever well tonight a
fan with the screen name frankie's realm
thinks he caught a mistake he says it
happened when i was talking about the
new great gatsby movie which was made in
3d
so remember the episode you put the
great gatsby 3d scenes in because you
said that they put that in because they
didn't have much stuff for 3d but the
movie is in 3d i watched the movie and
you can kind of tell that the director
was a little desperate to come up with
3d moments
for the great gatsby of course if
anything is not your liking i'll change
it
but you messed up you see sharks don't
growl sharks don't even have an organ to
make sounds the only sound they make
while going to the water is with their
jaw
that's the only sound they make yeah
shark stone growl good job idiot
that's kind of rude
well anyway i'm sorry frankie's realm if
that's even your real name
but you are dead wrong if you think we
made a mistake of course sharks don't
growl everyone knows that duh yeah
you screwed up because the scene went by
too fast for you alan could you please
roll the clip again but this time slow
it down
yeah
see
it was a bear driving the shark bears
growl
yeah
oh and by the way great news frankie's
realm we went ahead and gave you your
own video the 3d treatment enjoy
well you messed up you see sharks don't
well sharks don't even have an organ to
make sounds and like something maybe
while going to the water is with their
jaw that's the only song they make get
shark stone bro good job video
[Music]
[Applause]
so the challenge still stands
why would anyone submit an error now i
don't know if you think you've spotted
an error on our show reported at
teamcoco.com
i found an error we will sort it out
right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make chump
meat out of the maestro we'll take